so look man you look at Russia gate and
it was what did we learn about Russia
gate for those that don't know it was
nothing
there were several high-profile people
who were going on CNN and MSNBC saying I
have seen the evidence
it exists Trump did this right and then
what were they saying when they
testified privately I have not seen any
events I have no idea right and then it
wasn't until this year the evidence
actually came out they made it all up
and were cheating not only today I'm
sorry it's not just they Biden did this
right in with Obama like they both sat
together and they they plotted this out
we don't really to what extent but we
know they were involved at sea no they
were involved that's all I need to know
that Joe Biden that's proof there's
proof Joe Budden's incarnate several
lives net exactly why were they going
after Michael Flynn and now Michael
Flynn has basically been exonerated well
I don't wanna say exonerated because the
the the political disparately the
disparity and yeah perspective but the
charges are gone see these are the kind
of things that make me think that
there's no way Trump's part of the deep
state because they wanted the deep state
we're trying to stop him from becoming
president the conspiracy is that it's
all sure to show yeah make you think of
course but I don't believe the
conspiracy it either
no no no no they they they destroyed
Michael Flynn's life they did and they
even admitted this was in part of the
notes that in the conversation with I
think it I might want to factor me on
this one I'm pretty sure though in the
conversation they had it with Obama and
Biden someone said and I think the FBI
notes showed Michael Flynn's
conversation with Chris slack was on the
level yeah and they were like well go
after him anyway yep
so you know Obama's there Biden is there
yeah Biden did an unmasking request it's
a really really complicated story that's
what's really hard for the American
people is to understand the common with
this yeah the the web long story short
all is Mike Michael Flynn was a national
security adviser he had a conversation
with a Russian ambassador I believe and
asking not ask him not to escalate
sanction Wars saying you know please let
us come in and do our thing before this
escalation that was it yeah the
conversation was on the level most
people agreed in an informal meeting at
the White House with no legal counsel
present
flynn said he didn't talk to his Lackey
and they went gotcha he just lied to an
FBI agent and then they claimed that was
grounds they went to him and said if you
do not plead guilty we will investigate
your son and so Michael Flynn said I'll
do whatever you want the threat yep yeah
it was Joe Biden they think that Joe
Biden actually personally raised the
idea of investigating Michael Flynn he
mentioned the Logan act it was Biden who
mentioned the Logan act right yeah
long story short Michael Flynn did
nothing wrong literally nothing wrong it
was in his official duties at his job
who's an incoming a national secured
advisor I mean conversation but with
another country and they found an
obscure way to force him and threatening
his family yeah to plead guilty so that
they could keep pushing this fake theory
of Russian collusion they cheated they
lied they the whole thing was a scam you
know and I'm surprised Trump was able to
win on that one because they were doing
it for years investigate him not to be
fair Trump made a whole bunch of banana
peel moments
slipping around and falling you know
trying to be talked to firing go home
the less attacked but but he still ended
up winning on that one mm-hmm and now
they're going for the same strategy
Trump's gonna cheat again it's like no I
think you're gonna cheat yeah never
accepted the results of 2016 you hate
Trump
you've been accusing of scandal for
scandal trying to impeach him since he
got in office I think if Trump gets
re-elected you drop the hammer on them
we're gonna see a perp walk we're gonna
see tons of people it's gonna be a store
amazing
Lydia's face listen that's why they
won't let him win they have like any
means necessary and that's what I'm
saying they're firing on all cylinders
they are firing everything they've got
they are whipping the emotions of the
American public around their fingers my
work and I see it and it saddens me a
lot that I'm speaking up I'm being more
vocal than I've ever been in my life
that they're going crazy the fact
they're going after Bill Barr is that is
the really interesting thing to me yeah
bill Barr was one of the smartest moves
Trump has ever made because he was the
the Attorney General in the night he was
Attorney General right yeah yeah
in the 90s under I think what HW Bush
was it I think it was yeah so basically
you pulling out of retirement who
got a clean track record serving the
country mm-hmm
bring them back into the same thing and
now they're trying to smear him again
but it's not so easy right because it's
like you mean to tell me if he was
corrupt in the 90s you know it's like
mmm boys working for Trump now and he's
defending Trump it's like yeah maybe or
maybe you just want Trump to know maybe
there is a group of corrupt crony
politicians who have been hiring their
buddies and infecting our government
with their BS yeah to enrich themselves
and are losing money to do the cancel
just TPP with China because they have a
lot of money invested there well but
imagine this could you imagine how crazy
would be if like say I don't know
somebody working in government had a
foundation maybe a Secretary of State
okay had a foundation where they were
taking donations from foreign
governments while they were running the
administration like that could never
happen right right yeah I know that
reference yeah like what right so I'm
not I'm not here to pretend Trump is
perfect on anything I don't like most of
the people who run for office but dilbar
seems like it's on the level yes W yep
simply does and they don't have any
problems then back then no take a look
at Cavanaugh Cavanaugh was was was was
vetted when he became a federal judge
all of a sudden they surfaced
thirty-year-old allegations against him
and run him through through the over the
coals calling him evil yeah like this
this is a whole new level of in you know
insidious strange and weird
it's that anger it's that elephant
riding around that they are trying to
control everybody with it it's sad was
that what was the name of that guy who
he was a he was a the banker plot you
know the banker plot let me look at it
yeah but look at the banker plot this my
understanding was a conspiracy in like
the early nineteen hundred's was it
Smedley Butler was that his name it's a
film yeah it's a movie
something happens okay maybe maybe I'm
thinking of a movie but I'm pretty sure
something happened where a bunch of
super wealthy individuals we're trying
to convince like a high ranking military
official to overthrow the government and
give them control of everything we're
not able to find it well it's very race
oriented it's about no thing I'm
thinking of as
like bankers who are like we want get
financial control of the government and
they wanted this guy to overthrow it or
something maybe maybe people are gonna
you know comment in the in the chats
with what it is you couldn't find it
I'll do it later I'm having fun this
mash button he was a Marine hello people
are saying yeah it was a great marine in
US history
during his thirty four year career as a
Marine he participated military actions
of the Philippines China and Central
America and Caribbean imagine anything
about conspiracies really wonder why I
read that I'm not sure sounds
interesting the business of a political
conspiracy by business leaders overthrow
President Roosevelt okay we figured it
out wasn't the banker pause business I
read too much all runs and I'm like
sometimes I'm like did that was it in a
movie mmm my brain is fractured I'm
gonna use that in the future no I mean I
was correct that's the point
yeah I actually knew what I was talking
about it doesn't matter you said it the
business plot the reason I the reason I
bring that up is I you know look
conspiracies happen mm-hmm they're so
for all for all that we know you know
the Obama Gates stuff like think about I
know a lot of people firmly believe it
is true but I I firmly believe we need
hard evidence before I make any
assertions true but entertain the
possibility that Donald Trump for all of
his character defects and boy howdy are
there a lot is just a guy who want to be
President to help this country I think
and wanted to apply his knowledge to
economics and foreign trade and there is
a group of people who have infected our
federal government at the highest levels
who hired their buddies and are using
their power to subvert the American
people you know the more the more I
looked into Trump the more I I see that
to be a hundred percent true certainly
wants people to survive he wants people
to do well he appreciates people who do
would that work hard there tell you the
story about the dude I met who Trump
gave him a free iPod No
so this dude I knew in Chicago said that
he went when they built Trump Tower okay
he was going there for some reason like
a delivery
and as just walking in he knew that he
could hear people behind him mm-hmm so
he didn't really pay attention but he
walked up to the door and opened it and
then stepped aside to let them in and
then when he did it was Trump and
Trump's people yeah and then he let they
all walked past him and then he was like
whoa hey it's Trump and then Trump's
about ten feet in front of him he walks
in drops the door and then Trump stops
turned around and goes hey kid thanks
and throws an ipod nice was that when
iPods were like a big deal yeah it was
like the new iPod with Trump's music on
it too it was like whoa and they're
stories from pod it's dude it's actually
gold I wait when when Trump first got
elected I went to Trump Tower uh-huh and
he's got that restaurant in the ice
cream shop
mmm and I asked everybody what they
thought about him they loved him yeah
they all loved him
yeah some people would say like he would
come down in just give me one $2 bills
there's no like they're gonna give him
money that's not surprising
I asked what I think I asked somebody at
the ice cream shop or the restaurant or
whatever and I was like what do you
think and they're like he comes down
sometimes he's really nice to everybody
and I'm like you think what do you think
you believe what they say about him and
they were like no but some people think
Trump's playing it up for the media like
he's exaggerated his character and
politics
- like generate you know controversy and
buzz but the people who worked at the
tower they were like he's great
I have heard do you know what I've heard
what have you heard I've heard he paid
off a bunch of people's like medical
bills and student loans and stuff and he
does it really quietly who's like super
under the table by hilarious he never
asked for anything for that yeah I I
firmly believe that based on all of the
negative press that if you were if you
were to remove all of the negative press
actually just go back in town 2015 chomp
was like considered to be one of the
best people in the country you know like
he was a good dude he's a civil rights
leader he's all these really great
things yeah he stood next to Rosa Parks
and won won an award with her but as
soon as he ran as the Republican they do
what they do best yeah they call
everybody who runs the Republican racist
that's true white nationalist all that
evil stuff I did to call him a racist
means you know nothing about him that's
it from what I've learned about a minute
actually I think it's amazing the amount
of stuff that he's done for the
minorities in in this country blows me
away well I am it's the more I research
into him the more I really like him a
lot I'm but that's just a simple truth I
actually heard one of the best
explanations from this guy forgot his
name
it was in New York when they were doing
a shia labeouf thing with that flag i
camera what the flag was called not
divide us yeah he will not divide us and
there was a guy there anti-trump and I
was talking to him and I asked him what
he thought about Trump and he was like
ah you know Trump's he's got problems
out of these the worst guy in the world
but I think you know we definitely need
somebody as well habla yeah and it was a
black dude by the way so I asked him I
was like who do you think Trump is
racist and he goes oh yeah but he's the
least racist present we've ever had and
I was like wait hold on wait you think
he's racist but he's the least racist
you think Obama is more racist and he
was like yeah uh-huh well and and he
basically told me that he was like
listen man you gotta understand we had
presidents who are slave owners pretty
sure that means they were racist right
now Matt's a good point he goes Trump
he's his prejudices man of course I
think he's racist but compared to all
the rest of them he's the least racist
we've ever had hmm and I'm like that's a
really interesting way of putting it and
I think from a certain perspective it's
fair to say everybody has certain
prejudices well you know you're you are
attracted to people that look closer to
your own like not even like lights been
proven physical attractiveness people
that's kind of what I'm saying and we
forget that we're animals we are animals
all right we're were mammals you know
and it's like even today you know for
example I was talking to a friend of
mine a close friend of mine and I was
like it happens to be an African
American and it was telling me I was
like tell me tell me like to talk to me
about like what you went through and
grew up without being around white
people in general and changed schools
and finally saw his first white person
and was afraid of them just a
six-year-old you know first interaction
felt fear because it was something
different yeah it's innate in us too
it's it's it's something that you don't
know you don't understand you know and
that is the it's learned though that is
that it is a bad person that you know
that it in itself it's different you
know we have to that's why I think
proximity is the cure for a lot of these
biases and bigotry riot Hawaii the
segregationists terrify me exactly I
agree like Don Lemon was talking to
Terry Crews right and they were talking
about how like you know he was trying to
drive home that it isn't it isn't like
or Terry Crews was saying it you know
it's not it's not white on black it's
not black on white it's like everyone is
in their own clusters and that's where
the crime happens to each other and it's
like sure but when we when we diversify
when we come together you know and find
out we're all pretty much the same we
all want to be loved we want to eat and
be comfortable and live life happily
you know man it the fact that there I
said this the other day and I'll say
eight a million times the fact that
there's a white progressive calling a
black conservative a white supremacist
proves race has nothing to do with it
exactly it is ideology exactly straight
away I mean and and when they're you you
see black people killing each other you
know all like non-stop like we look at
New York what's happening Chicago
Atlanta like all these places it's
happening and yeah there's people there
there's a very small group that are
actually still speaking up for them but
it is just being lost well it's because
the political completely it's it's the
the mainstream politics doesn't care
about it they can't weaponize it yep
exactly so you have this the cause of
this crime has a lot to do with poverty
and culture mm-hmm like so so it's gang
culture for instance yeah gang culture
isn't the biggest issue is the biggest
factor is my understanding having
covered some the stuff in Chicago it's
actually just general I don't know them
it's it's not gang culture it's some
kind of like just they don't have a
respect for life that's its culture I
wasn't to do with race well as amplified
by my neighborhood they're trying to
bring society down but the society has
given you this comfortable life well
these far-left activists are okay right
right in Chicago there's a very little
thought to like if you if you mess with
my friends in my neighborhood we go we
dial 211 yeah you know so in my
neighborhood it was like this this
culture was bred across all different
races you have the southside of Chicago
where there's a lot of poverty and there
is a culture of violence and an anger
and dialing the knob all the way up like
I told you this really like last week or
two weeks ago that there was a fight
outside of the high school in my
neighborhood and it was like it was like
it was it was it was a glorious diverse
group of people hating each other
it's great right and one guy drew a gun
they were boxing one guy lost he reached
under a car where he hit a weapon he
pulled out a gun
oh no he pulled out a 2x4 and then the
other guy was like oh you want to bring
a weapon huh and then he walked over and
was trying to grabbed a gun and then
everyone started screaming and running
no and it was like that that mentality
of like violence and taking things up to
the extreme level of we were hitting
each other and now I'm just gonna shoot
you that's just part of like some weird
culture that exists to quote one of my
favorite movies Evo pickets evil so I
think it's in the Bible what do you get
with like Karen co-chairmen with like
high level upper middle class Karen's I
will sue you no I will sue you no I will
sue you and that's the extent to which
they take things yeah it's like
litigation mm-hmm but it's a it's a it's
a it's a cultural phenomenon and it's
not it's it's completely not racial as
evidenced by the fact that you have
wealthy conservative black people
arguing with you know like middle-class
white progressives about who's the real
white supremacist right exactly
completely disproves the narrative of
the left that there aren't like if they
ever stopped and actually just like
stepped back and watched a video of what
they were doing
yeah then they would realize race wasn't
a factor and it wouldn't that be
wonderful if they actually stopped it
for a second and and just took a look at
what they're doing and maybe maybe read
a history book
you know yeah good luck with that one
huh thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you